>> Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome back Director,
Product Management,
Google, Greg DeMichillie.
[ Music ]
>> Greg: Good morning.
Welcome back to day
two of GCP Next.
Thank you all for coming back.
I hope you had a
good day yesterday.
I hope you had fun at
the after dark party.
Did folks make that?
Good, good.
I hope you get time or have had
time today to experience the
playground that's out there.
My two favorite ones are
the emotobooth where you can
experience the vision
API in a firsthand way.
Get your picture taken.
See if you can trick it on what
emotions you're feeling and then
query it, the game where you
actually can compete with
somebody else and then to see
what you know about reddit or
Wikipedia or a whole bunch
of huge data sources with
BigQuery.
I hope you also got time to look
at the various partners that are
out there showing off solutions
or add-ons or other software
that works with Google Cloud.
You know and it's really
valuable to me and rewarding to
see so many of you
talking with each other,
to see customers
giving sessions,
to see partners giving
sessions and sharing your own
experiences.
There's also one thing -- I
hope you'll do me a favor.
You know, those of us who are
lucky enough to be on stage at
events like this are just the
most visible part of many, many,
many people's work.
Whether it's the people who
build the demos that you saw;
people who build the
products, the sessions;
the staging and the event people
who transformed an empty shell
of a building into
this amazing venue;
our wonderful creative partners
at Instrument who helped come up
with this amazing lighting
design that you have.
Would you join me in thanking
them before we dive into all
that?
[ Applause ]
Thank you, they
really are remarkable.
Today is going to be a
little bit different.
Today we're going to give you
deep dives into three critical
technology areas.
You're going to hear from the
engineering leaders at Google
who are closest to these
technologies who have been
working to really build out what
we think of as Google and Google
Cloud.
There's no marketing today.
You're hearing directly
from engineers.
We picked these topics because
we think they're the ones that
are most critical in the
evolution of Cloud over the next
-- not just year, be
the next several years.
And frankly, because we're nerds
at heart and we think the stuff
is pretty cool.
Our first speaker is Joe Kava.
Joe runs all data center
operations at Google.
And, you know, they're actually
a kind of legendary team within
Google because we depend upon
what they do to an incredible
degree and it's so easy to
take for granted the amazing
innovations.
So to give us a look inside
at Google data centers,
how we build them,
how we operate them,
and the kind of
innovation we do,
would you please join me
in welcoming to the stage,
Joe Kava, Joe?
>> Thank you, very much.
Thanks, Greg.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Joe Kava.
And I'm responsible for the
teams that design, build,
and operate Google's
data centers worldwide.
So today I would like to share
with you a little bit about our
culture and our guiding
principles, really,
what is the secret sauce that
makes Google data centers so
unique?
So, first, imagine your data
center whether it's a private
enterprise data center or
a multi-tenant co-location
facility.
But now you don't have to
imagine anymore because with
Google Cloud Platform, your data
center is Google's data centers.
GCP gives you access to
high-performance computing
available around the world in
our highly secure and ultra
reliable data centers.
So let me delve a little bit
into what makes Google data
centers so special,
why we're unique.
First, the core principles of
our data center program are
availability, security,
and performance.
You know, at the core of our
program is our commitment to
availability.
I've been doing this a long time
and I have evaluated literally
dozens if not hundreds of data
centers all over the world both
public and private.
And I can tell you,
without a doubt,
they are not all
created equally.
First, when we say 7 by
24, we absolutely mean it.
Our designs are fault tolerant
and hardened against failure,
our critical infrastructure
is concurrently maintainable.
This means that when something
does break or when maintenance
is required, we can do that
without taking down any part of
our critical infrastructure.
This makes it invisible to you.
Next, we design our data centers
with an eye towards the future.
So we're always building in
hooks into our designs that
allow us to upgrade our systems
and our network so that we can
always keep ahead or -- and
keep current with the latest
platforms developments.
And lastly, we staff our data
centers 24 by 7 with Googlers,
our own team of Googlers that
have been intimately involved
with design, to construction,
commissioning of the systems,
and operations of
the data centers.
So, second, security.
This is truly of utmost
importance in the Google data
center program.
Google's focus on security among
is our primary design criteria.
Our physical security model
features layered security that
includes things like custom
design access cards, alarms,
vehicle access barriers, metal
detectors, perimeter fencing,
biometrics, and even laser
intrusion detection guarding the
data center floor.
Our data centers are monitored
24 by 7 by high resolution
cameras internal and external.
They can detect and
track any intruders.
And our data centers are
constantly patrolled by our
security teams that have
undergone rigorous background
investigations and training.
And as you get closer to
the data center floor,
and to our core network,
the security increases.
Access to the data center floor
is only available through a
secure corridor that implements
multifactor authentication so
you need an authorized badge and
biometric clearance to get on to
the data center floor.
And only approved employees that
have a business need to be there
ever get access to the data
center floor or our core
network.
In fact, less than 1% of all
Googlers ever set foot on the
data center at Google.
We employ a very strict
end-to-end chain of custody for
our storage systems, from the
first time a hard drive goes
into a machine until it is
verified as clean, erased,
or destroyed, we know every
movement of that hard drive.
We know who, the person; when,
the time stamps; we know what,
the serial number and the
state of the media; and why,
its next expected action.
And information security and
physical security go hand in
hand in our data centers.
You know, data is most
vulnerable when it's travelling
across the Internet
or within networks.
And for this reason, securing
data in transit is a high
priority to Google.
Data travelling between a
customer's device and a Google
data center is encrypted
using httpstls.
And as a matter of fact, Google
was the first major cloud
provider to make this
default by standard.
Our last guiding
principle is performance.
You know, we've been leaders
in developing ultra high
performance compute systems
since the earliest days at
Google.
Our high-performance computing
is the result of optimizing
throughout the entire stack.
Nearly all of our infrastructure
is custom-designed and
purpose-built for
our computing needs.
From our own dedicated
high-voltage subsystems on site
to the electrical distribution
systems and our cooling systems,
they're all working in
conjunction to provide the
highest level of performance
and the lowest total cost of
ownership.
When I first joined Google,
I was kind of amazed at the
extraordinary lengths that the
company goes to to develop our
own computing systems.
And, of course, over time I
learned why, but at the time,
it wasn't so intuitive to me.
Why do we build our own servers?
Why not just buy?
Well, we go through all of this
extraordinary effort to create
our own because frankly, what we
needed at our scale didn't exist
when we started.
To achieve the performance
efficiency and price targets
that were necessary, we had
to build our own servers,
we had to invent hardware, we
had to develop the software,
we had to create a culture
for scale and reliability.
Google servers don't include any
unnecessary components such as
video cards, chip sets, or
peripheral devices which can
introduce vulnerabilities.
Our production servers run a
custom-designed operating system
based on a stripped down and
hardened version of Linux.
And Google's IP data network
consists of our own fiber,
public fiber, and
undersea cables.
This allows us to
deliver highly available,
low latency services
across the globe.
But it also means that we can
respond faster to demand and
provide the capacity you need.
From my earliest days at Google,
our data center program has been
as much committed to our
culture as it has been to our
principles.
The key tenants of our
culture are ownership.
Sustainability, and innovation.
We have Googlers that
operate our data centers.
You see, the norm in the
industry is for the design build
contractor to hand over a set
of drawings and a set of owners
manuals and the keys to the
front door and wish the data
center operator, good luck.
Well, and all too often,
frankly, those operations teams,
they aren't even
employed by the owner.
They're outsourced to
the lowest cost bidder.
And if there's on certainty in
data center operations it's that
problems and faults are going
to happen in the middle of the
night, typically on Sundays,
when no one else is available to
help out.
So we take a different approach.
Firstly, we hire the best and
the brightest engineers in
operations professionals that
come from diverse backgrounds
but they all have
one common trait,
they are systems thinkers.
Many of our team members
come from mission critical
environments like the navy
nuclear submarine program where
mistakes can be catastrophic.
They understand how systems
interact and how they work
together.
Further, we've built regional
teams at all of our data center
Campuses that are comprised of
the engineers responsible for
design and construction, working
side-by-side with the operations
teams.
The experience and
qualifications of our staff is
unparalleled.
The majority of our staff
hold advanced degrees,
they have professional licenses,
they're published in technical
papers and in books, they
hold patents relative to our
industry, and together,
these integrated teams are
responsible for
building the capacity,
commissioning the systems, and
operating these data centers,
7 by 24.
This gives us an unparalleled
level of ownership end-to-end of
our infrastructure.
But for these teams to
truly be successful,
they need to have advanced
realtime visibility into the
status and the functionality
of our infrastructure.
As you know, to say that Google
is obsessed with data might be a
little bit of an understatement.
So to aid our teams, we built
world class monitoring and
control systems for all
of the functional areas,
from the servers and storage
and networking systems to our
electrical distribution systems
and the security systems.
We're monitoring all aspects
of performance and operations,
truly from chip to chiller.
But equally important to
our culture of ownership and
transparency -- I'm sorry --
equally important to our culture
of ownership is transparency
and continual learning.
So when issues do occur, we
learn from them and we can share
the learning with all of
our teams around the world.
You know, we studied the
root cause of failures in the
industry based on
published data.
And on the infrastructure side,
the industry norm is that human
error still accounts for
the overwhelming majority of
incidents.
However, because of our designs
and our highly qualified people,
only a very small fractions of
our incidents were related to
human error and none of
them caused downtime.
You know, for as long as I've
been building and operating data
centers, I've been an
advocate for efficiency and
sustainability.
It takes a tremendous amount
of power to run at our scale.
And we have to be good
stewards for the environment,
to minimize our impact,
and reduce our consumption.
We've been committed to
sustainability since the
earliest days of our
data center program.
We've been carbon
neutral since 2007.
We've received an A-grade from
the carbon disclosure project
for the last two years running.
All of our sites are ISO-14001
and 50001 certified for
environmental protection and
energy management and we're
consistently at the top
of Greenpeace's cool IT
leaderboard.
You know, shamefully, though,
sustainability doesn't matter to
a lot to folks in our industry.
It isn't even a criteria in
Gartner's Magic Quadrant for
data center cloud providers.
Well, it does matter.
It matters to me.
It matters to many of you.
And it should matter to them.
[ Applause ]
So let's -- thank you.
So let's work together.
Let's send a message to Gartner.
Have them get onboard.
Let's make this important
and let's make it a criteria.
And for us, energy efficiency is
truly at the heart of our data
center sustainability program.
We believe that the best energy
saved is the energy not consumed
in the first place.
That's why we've pioneered
hyperefficient computing systems
and data centers.
And for that fact, our data
centers consume on average only
half of the energy compared to a
typical enterprise data center.
This has enabled us to be the
first cloud provider to offer
pricing based on
Moore's Law Scale.
But we are equally committed to
powering our infrastructure with
renewable energy.
As a matter of fact, we are the
world's largest private investor
in renewable energy.
To date, we've invested more
than $2 billion in power
purchase agreements.
These PPAs are very
important because, one,
we're buying the entire output
of wind and solar farms for long
periods of time,
typically 10 to 20 years.
These winds farms are on the
same power grids as our data
centers.
And this gives the project developer the financial
commitment and certainty
they need to get the project
developed and so we know
that our investment is adding
renewable power to the grid that
otherwise would not have been
made available.
And lastly, at the heart of
our culture is innovation.
No matter how good our
systems are performing,
no matter how well our
teams are performing,
we always believe
we can do better.
We have a relentless
focus on innovation.
In fact, since I've
been at Google,
we have redesigned our
fundamental cooling technology
on average every
12 to 18 months.
And along the way, we've
pioneered innovations in
water-based cooling systems such
as sea water cooling for data
centers, industrial canal water,
recycled or reuse water cooling
systems, rain water harvesting,
storm water capture and reuse,
and thermal energy
storage systems.
And we've designed data centers
that don't use water cooling at
all.
Instead they use 100%
outside air cooled.
So the point here is that there
is no one size fits all model at
Google.
Each data center is designed
for the highest performance,
the highest efficiency for
that specific location.
We don't rest on our laurels.
We've also invested a lot in
robotic innovation for our data
centers.
This is one example of a fully
automated disc erase environment
which allows for faster, more
efficient throughput and better
inventory management
of our hard drives.
And lately, we've pioneered the
use of machine learning and deep
learning algorithms for
data center operations.
As you can imagine, our data
centers are very large and
complex.
They are electrical and
mechanical in control systems
all working together to try
to get the best performance.
But the sheer number of
interactions and operating
parameters makes it really
impossible for us mere mortals
to understand how to optimize
a data center in realtime.
However, it really is pretty
trivial for computers to crunch
through all of those scenarios
and find the optimal settings.
So, over the past
couple of years,
we've developed these algorithms
and we've trained them with
billions of data points from all
of our data centers all over the
world.
Now we use this machine learning
to help our teams visualize the
data so the operations teams
can know how to set up the
electrical and mechanical plants
for the optimal settings on that
given day.
And often these consider up to
19 independent variables that
affect performance.
This helps our team identify
any discontinuities or any
inflection points in the curves
that might not be intuitive
otherwise.
Now, as you can imagine, with
the explosive growth in public
-- in public cloud computing,
we've had some fairly aggressive
expansion going on ourselves.
So let's take a look
at a short video,
never before seen in public, of
our data center campus in Iowa.
Roll the video, please?
[ Music ]
Okay.
What you're looking at
right there --
[ Applause ]
Thank you, thank you very much.
Yeah, come on.
I mean, who doesn't love
data centers, right?
What you're looking at right
here is the world's largest data
center campus.
Look at the size of the trucks.
Those are construction trucks.
Look at them for scale.
Each of these building pads is
over a third of a mile long with
multistoried data centers.
We know that long-term capacity
planning is very difficult.
Everyone struggles with it.
And we have been growing and
keep growing to meet your needs
and keep ahead of your needs.
So with capacity like this,
when you're ready to grow,
we'll be ready for you.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
Yeah. Okay.
So, today we have 13 operational
data center campuses on four
continents and there are
two more currently under
development.
Our global network brings our
data centers closer together and
closer to you, with more than
70 points of presence in 33
countries.
This ensures the same low
latency and responsiveness that
you expect from Google's own
services is now available to you
on GCP also.
And cloud platform is available
at these locations including our
newly announced Japan
and Oregon regions,
and there's ten more that
are coming throughout 2017.
And lastly, I'd like to remind
you about our new 360 tour of
our data center in Oregon.
It's really cool.
It's like a virtual walkthrough
of one of Google's data centers.
It's available in the
playground area outside.
And for those on livestream, you
can experience it for yourself
at the following link.
So, thank you all very much.
It's been a pleasure
being with you here today.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> You know, one of the fun
things about working at Google
is working with people who are
passionate about what they do.
And I think that just comes
across so clearly that Joe is
passionate about his work.
So, that's data centers.
Our second speaker in our
second topic is about security.
Niels Provos is a distinguished
engineer at Google focused on
security and privacy.
Now for context, there are only
about 50 distinguished engineers
inside all of Google.
Now -- and according
to his Wikipedia page,
in his spare time he
turns steel into swords.
You know, security is different
than many other features.
It's an opportunity for
us to work with you,
to create the best possible
security environment for you,
your customers.
And with GCP, we have a great
opportunity to put more and more
of the tools that we use to
manage our security into your
hands so that you can manage
your security as well.
So with that, I'm really
delighted and honored to bring
up on stage, Niels Provos,
distinguished engineer from
Google.
Niels?
>> Thank you for the
introduction, Greg.
Good morning, everybody.
As Greg said, I'm a
distinguished engineer at
Google.
I am responsible for the
security and privacy engineering
teams.
Today I would like to pull back
the covers a little bit and
share with you a glimpse on
how we pervasively secure you,
your data, your customers' data,
and your applications when you
run on top of Google's
Cloud Platform.
However, let me set the
stage a little bit first.
At the recent Enigma Conference
in San Francisco, Rob Joyce,
the head of NSA's tailored
access operations made the
following statements on how
advanced adversaries managed to
break into your
systems and networks.
Now I understand that most of
you would like to spend your
time and focus on building a
great product and great new
features for your customers.
However, your adversaries, they
focus their time and energy on
finding weak spots in your
systems that they can exploit.
Fortunately, at Google I lead
a team of experts who builds
systems and processes
specifically designed to thwart
adversaries.
We do this by anticipating
them, preventing them,
protecting them, disrupting
them, and containing them.
And we will work with you to
make sure that you can meet your
requirements and that you
can leverage our security
capabilities on top
of the platform.
So now I would like to give you
a little more insight on how we
think about security at Google
and how we have created a secure
infrastructure for ourself.
Google security and privacy team
consists of over 500 people who
continuously work to protect
our infrastructure and you when
you're running on top of GCP.
Due to our scale, we end up
seeing all kinds of bad behavior
across the internet, phishing
e-mails, malware websites,
network attacks.
We also see all kinds of
adversaries ranging from all
levels of sophistication,
not just script kiddies and
cybercriminals, but also
nation-state actors.
Now at Google, we are not
pursuing a hard shell pyramidal
model.
Instead, we are really focused
on pervasive defense and depth.
This is similar to the immune
system analogy that Urs
mentioned yesterday.
There are two key principles
running pervasively to our
approach to security.
And that is trust
and transparency.
That means that we design for
trust throughout our stack and
we build in the transparency
so that you can verify for
yourself.
And, in fact, this talk is one
of our steps in giving you more
transparency.
Now, I'll be talking about
Google's infrastructure in the
first part of the
talk, you know,
how we think about
security there.
And then in the second
part of the talk,
I will explain how that applies
to you when you run on top of
GCP.
In order to facilitate
this discussion,
we have split our stack
into eight different layers.
And I'll be walking from
the bottom up, you know,
starting with the hardware to
the boot process all the way up
to the deployment,
operations, and usage.
At the hardware layer, we are
fortunate enough that we operate
at such a skill that we can
build our own proprietary secure
systems.
That means that we have
purposeful hardware for
computing, storage, networking,
all the way through the full
data centers as you just
heard Joe talk about.
Our ability to design and deploy
custom hardware means that we
can maintain provenance and
establish trust at the hardware
level.
Now, on top of this
trusted hardware,
it's important that we can
also boot in a trusted way.
And to accomplish that, we
have employed code signing that
allows us to verify the BIOS,
the boot loader and the kernel.
And that means that only the
intended software can run on
Google's infrastructure.
So now that we know that our
machines have booted in the
known good state, it's also
important that all of our jobs
communicate in an authenticated
and authorized fashion.
To accomplish that, we have
built a cryptographic key
distribution system called Laws
that allows us to establish
cryptographic identities
for all jobs that run on our
infrastructure.
We know and audit the binaries
that run so we can establish
trust not only at the operating
system but also for the Apps
that are running on it.
Now, we have heard a lot
about virtual machines.
And one of the properties we
really need there is secure
isolation.
At Google, we use KVM as our
hypervisor technology and we are
significantly invested
to harden the security.
That means that our security
teams have found 15 of the last
21 in publicly known
vulnerabilities in KVM.
That means that we are the first
to fix, and the first to patch,
but, of course, we also
contribute our findings back to
the community so that everybody
can benefit from a more secure
KVM technology.
We continue on working to
make KVM even more secure.
To get a secure operating
system imagine on our machines,
we have created a Google curated
image that we run throughout our
production infrastructure.
This is very similar to the
recommendation from the NSA of
having a secure baseline.
We have also deployed a
service that alerts us of
vulnerabilities and third party
source code to further protect
our services.
Now at the storage layer, it's
really important that all access
to data is individually
authorized and ACL'd.
Before we write data to disk, we
chunk it and spread it so that
not all data ends up
on the same server.
We also encrypt data, and
metadata individually and to
protect these encryption keys,
we have built a system called
Keystore that wraps them
by encrypting them further.
Our storage systems only install
this wrap key and never the
original cryptographic key that
will be required to decrypt the
data and that means that
all access to data requires
interaction with Keystore which
gives us logging and auditing
capabilities.
Similar, for data in motion,
we encrypted when the troubles
between systems that we control.
We accomplish fine grain control
over access with our internal
IM systems and they also give us logging and auditing
capabilities.
So, now at this point, we are
running on trusted hardware.
We know that the boot process
was trusted and we trust our
operating system and we also
have provenance for hardware
boot and wares.
We encrypt the data and we know
that all access is authenticated
and authorized.
Now, to secure our applications,
we're pursuing multiple layered
approaches.
One of them is that we have
built a binary on configuration
verification system.
That means that for
all applications,
we know how they were built, we
know how they were configured,
and we know how
they were deployed.
And for each of these steps,
we know who was responsible for
them.
To put additional security
into our development process,
we require that all
code gets peer reviewed.
That means there's a second pair
of eyes that looks at the code
before it's being committed
so that we can find bugs and
security problems very early on.
To help our teams create
more secure systems,
we also require security review
before anything can launch.
That means that we can put
security into our products right
at the design phase.
However, you know, even
with the best practices,
you still cannot prevent
all security problems.
And so we have created a
security scanning technology
that allows us to find many
of the common mistakes,
cross side scripting, mixed
content, mixed pending,
more strange attacks
such as a Rosetta Flash.
And we have also used this as an
example where we can contribute
back to the community.
We have made our firing
range test bed open source.
That is if anybody else would
like to develop their own
security scanning technology,
we already have a ready-made App
that they can test against.
So at this point, our
applications are reviewed,
they've been tested.
We believe they don't
have vulnerabilities,
data is encrypted, and
access is authorized.
But now it's time to expose
these applications to the
dangerous web.
There are a multiple different
ways in which we secure our
applications there.
First of all, on the network,
we protect the traffic with TLS.
To prevent many of
the middle attacks,
we have put certificate pinning
into our Chrome browser so that
we only trust the
right certificates.
We have also deployed
unphishable user identity to our
users with unphishable hardware
second factors and to protect
against network attacks, we
have built in DDoS protection.
Some of you might have heard
recently about Project Shield
where we announced that we're
extending this DDoS protection
to news and human rights
organizations as well as
election monitoring sites.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
At the operations level, we have
built technology that allows us
to patch and monitor, do
incident response, forensics,
threat analysis and
threat intelligence.
And this is also another example
where we have contributed back
to the open source by making
some of our forensic tools
available such as GRR or
recall for memory analytics.
Now, one of the sayings that we
have is the first user who is
going to be hitting your
application is likely going to
be an App user.
So we give our developers
the tools to be able to do
reputation checks on
your apps and binaries.
We have automated
analysis of traffic,
and to find botnets that
might be engaging in spam.
And we also leverage our global
view on botnets to build threat
intelligence on bad actors
and current attack factors.
However, to reduce the overall
attack surface that we face and
that our users face
on the internet,
and that all of you face, we
created Project Zero in 2014.
It's a team dedicated to finding
zero data vulnerabilities in
critical internet software.
You may have heard about the
Heartbleed Bug in open SSL.
Urs mentioned that
briefly yesterday,
or about rowhammer where just
reading memory can lead to
remote code execution.
And most recently we announced
a widespread security
vulnerability in GDIPC.
So that means that we have
a team that finds, you know,
critical security problems
that are very widely spread.
And, you know, we get
the benefit of, you know,
knowing about these first so we
can fix our infrastructure but
we can also work with the rest
of the community to make sure
that we get the internet
infrastructure, you know,
fixed in general.
As I mentioned in
the previous slide,
you're writing secure
software is difficult.
And Google has been one of the
first companies to create a
vulnerability rewards program
where we ask researchers across
the world with helping find
security bugs in our products
and just last year we paid out
over $2 million to hundreds of
researchers who helped us
build more secure products.
So now let's switch over to GCP.
I have just told you and I hope
you understand a little better
about the security capabilities
that we have built for
ourselves.
You might wonder, that's
great, but, you know,
how does that apply to us
and when we run on GCP?
These security capabilities
that I mentioned to you is what
enables our Google
developers to lift, you know,
the V3 cloud experience,
the next cloud experience.
It means that they can
focus on building, you know,
amazing products and they do
not have to be security experts.
Now we understand that many of
you are on a spectrum on how you
develop and manage your
applications and that all of you
are going to be at different
points in your journey to this
next version of Cloud.
We understand that you may
have to manage and segment your
network to create trust zones or
you need more explicit control
over the firewall of
the network parameter.
All of you need logging
and auditing capabilities.
And we are really committed
to help you meet your goals
wherever you are on your journey
to this next version of the
cloud.
And to accomplish that, we are
increasingly making more of
these capabilities available to
you and I'll be explaining to
you a little bit how that
is going to look like.
So I mentioned, you
know, previously,
we had eight layers in
recognition of the needs that
many of you need better
control over the network.
We have introduced the
network layer here.
So, I mentioned to you what it
is that we do at the hardware
level, what it is that we
do at our boot process,
and for the operating
system level.
You're actually benefitting off
all of these mechanisms already
because GCP is built
on top of this.
Many of you have also
compliance requirements and our
infrastructure is regularly
audited by external auditors for
SOC 213, ISO 2701, PCI DSS
3.0 and for Google Compute and
Google Cloud Storage,
Cloud SQL and BigQuery.
We're also covered
under the HIPPA-BAA.
That means that you can build
on top of an infrastructure
foundation that is regularly
audited and certified.
For cloud, at the storage level,
all data is already encrypted by
default.
To give you even greater control
on how data is being stored at
rest, we have made customer
supplied encryption keys made
available to you and we
also give you audit logging
capabilities.
In the future, we plan on giving
you even more control with a key
management system that allows
you to manage your own keys,
you know, generate them, rotate
them, suspend, resume them,
delete them, or manage the
import and export of secrets.
Yesterday, you've heard about our IM system that we have not
made available to you which gives you explicit role-based
access control.
And we will give you additional
capabilities later on in the
year.
Now at the network layer, many
of you require explicit control.
In fact, today, there are
already many ways in which you
can customize your network such
as with isolated IP groups,
private IP addresses,
BPNs, or inbound firewalls.
We're working on extending
and expanding these features,
including outbound firewalls.
When you run on
Google App Engine,
you already can benefit from
the security scanning technology
that I mentioned to you earlier
with the Cloud security scanner.
We're working on
creating more scanners,
and on increasing the scanning
capabilities so you can also use
it on GCE and GKE.
We also plan to give you the
ability to sign your binaries so
that you can verify and enforce
what gets to run as part of your
infrastructure.
We're also thinking of giving
you source code security
capabilities; however, that
requires that you first store
your source code with us, so
please check out the Google
Cloud source repositories.
For protecting your
developers and users,
we already give you the
options of using security keys,
which gives you this, you know,
unphishable hardware second
factor.
Many of you at the moment may
be relying on this sort of,
you know, hard network parameter
that I've been talking about
earlier.
We also plan on giving you
detailed and sophisticated
identity and
authorization tools,
that means that you can write
access policy not just based on
the user, but also on
the machine and location.
You may have heard about the
Beyond Corp model yesterday.
That sort of goes
in that direction.
When you leverage Google
scale by using, let's say,
the https load balancer, you
also benefit from built-in DDoS
protection.
To protect your SSL
and TLS certificates,
we have been working for years
on something that is called
certificate transparency, that
essentially creates publicly
verifiable logs that give you
provenance and trust for the
certificates for
your own domains.
For operations, you already
benefit essentially from all the
practices that we have for
the underlying infrastructure,
where we, you know,
regularly patch and upgrade.
However for your own projects,
we are looking into giving you
an integrated view that gives
you an idea of the patch level
of vulnerabilities for
your own deployments,
and we're also thinking of ways
of adding some of our threat
intelligence into that view.
You already can benefit from
audit logging and stack driver
to give you a better idea and
detailed records of what's going
on with your infrastructure
and your data.
In the future we plan on giving
you strong authors of how second
factoring for logging
into your projects,
but we're also investigating
additional app use signals that
we might be able to make
available to you when you
develop your applications, such
as URL and binary reputation.
So these are just some of the
security capabilities that we
will increasingly make available
to you to access and control.
You already have the option for
us to manage the security and
the platform, if you use, for
example, Google App Engine,
but we also planned on giving
you the ability to leverage an
increasing array of security
features that you can manage to
your own requirements.
And to be clear, our goal here
is to provide you the control
you need on the trusted
and transparent Cloud,
so that you do not have to
become security experts,
but can instead focus on
innovation and creating a great
business.
Thank you very much.
[Applause]
>> Thank, Niels, very much.
Our final topic we want to
talk about is the evolution in
containers.
And who better to talk
about that than Eric Brewer.
Eric is a pioneer
in Cloud computing.
In fact, before
coming to Google,
he built one of the world's
first scalable clusters.
He's been involved in industry
and academia as being on the
staff at U.C. Berkeley.
He's been a champion inside
Google for this notion of a move
to a third wave of computing
driven by what we can do with
containers.
He's going to talk about
Kubernetes and he's going to
give you a view of some of the
deeper implications and where we
see this technology evolving
over the next few years.
So would you please join me in
welcoming on stage Eric Brewer.
Eric?
[ Music ]
>> All right.
Thank you so much, Greg.
If you were to ask me
what my job was at Google,
I would, having now thought
about it a little bit,
say what's next?
That's a fun job to have.
Today we'll talk
about containers,
which for the past few
years have been what's next.
And we've made a lot
of progress on that,
especially through Kubernetes,
but I also want to talk about
some things we
haven't gotten to.
So I view this era as kind
of the Cloud-native era.
And what I mean by that is the
applications you build are built
to run natively in the Cloud.
You're expecting to take use
-- make use of Cloud resources,
you're expecting to have an
infinite number of machines,
essentially, and things
you can easily scale.
All right.
So that's a wonderful
place to be.
It's built on top of containers,
that's certainly an important
part of it.
It's very dynamic because you
can change not only the number
of services you have,
the kinds -- for example,
with custom images, you can have
as much RAM or CPU as you want.
There is no physical
machine like that actually.
So these are literally rote
machines in that senses.
And we're moving to a
model of microservices,
not necessarily because we
want the services per se,
but we want the decoupling
that the services give you,
so that you can have a lot of
different people and a lot of
different teams
working well together.
So this has been
enabled by Kubernetes,
and I'll talk about
that some today.
In particular, the way it allows
you to do production versions of
containers.
But one thing we haven't
really gotten to is so, fine,
I can have a container,
I can schedule it,
but how do I actually manage
my whole app and evolve it,
and how do I configure it?
Because when I think about
things that have been tricky
inside Google, configuration
actually is always at the top of
the list.
I would say when we have
software errors internally that
cause problems, configuration
errors are high among them,
right?
It's kind of a nasty little
area that's hard to get right.
And I'm going to talk about
what's next for that in
particular today, hopefully
make some progress.
Now, we've been using containers
for more than ten years.
Our definition of containers
didn't start with Docker.
It predates that by a long way.
It started really
with LINUX containers,
which we were putting in
for performance isolation.
So the first thing we want out
of containers is performance
isolation.
We did this through C groups,
which we contributed to LINUX
about 10 years ago.
Name spaces have been added.
There's lots of features that
are about the isolation aspects
of containers.
That's what gives us isolation,
so we can run many different
jobs on the same physical nodes.
Docker came along and did
a really nice job with the
packaging.
We have had packaging inside
Google for 10 years of various
flavors, but I will admit the
Docker version for packaging,
at least, is a little cleaner.
In particular, they have an
overlay file system that allows
you to compose different
pieces into a single entity,
and it does a nice job with
how you handle libraries.
So for example, if your
container is immutable,
it includes the libraries
you need and, therefore,
it runs the same on a laptop
as it does on the Cloud.
We'll come back to that
point about immutability,
because it's something
I want to build on.
On the Kubernetes front, it's
really about trying to bring --
the way we think about using a
native production to the Cloud.
In particular, we started
with Borg and Omega,
these are -- you know, Borg is
more than 10 years old at this
point, that is the scheduler
for the internal jobs at Google.
But it's actually more
than just a scheduler.
It's actually implicit
in its ecosystem,
in things like load balancing
and naming and discovery and
health checking and how
you move jobs around.
So we wanted to take the lessons
from Borg and rebuild them into
Kubernetes, which I think
we've done actually quite well.
And then talk about how you
use that to get a Google-like
experience.
And I'll say what that means.
In particular, the biggest
change between Borg and
Kubernetes is not
the functionality,
it's the fact that Kubernetes
is open source, right?
Borg is a complete giant
monolithic thing that we
couldn't possibly open source,
and you wouldn't want it if we
could, actually, right?
But it's a great thing to learn
from and Kubernetes takes the
best of it and has really made it something that is much more
usable and much cleaner.
So despite being
only 20 months old,
Kubernetes is already the top
.01 percent of GitHub projects,
it's had 27,000 commits,
which is a crazy number.
In fact, we had to add staff
just to deal with pull requests.
Pull requests you get when
you have that many commits,
it's crazy, right?
That is a very healthy
sign of the community,
and that's really the reason
we open source it is to get that
community participation and
frankly to enable hybrid and
multiCloud performance.
So these two work together,
Docker for packaging and
Kubernetes for -- for
management of containers.
And so what do I think of as the
things that Kubernetes needs to
provide, which are previously the things that were in the Borg
ecosystem -- are in the Borg ecosystem.
In particular, it's things like how you provision the nodes and
attach the storage.
It's how you connect to the
containers, both directly,
which is actually not
the case that matters,
and indirectly through
load balancing.
So deep in the kind of design
of Kubernetes is how you do load
balancing, right?
You really kind of can't use
Kubernetes without automatically
using load balancing
all over the place.
And that is pretty fundamental
because load balancing is
actually really
about availability.
It's how we decouple which pods
are up from the name of the
service that you're
using, right?
So as long as the load balancer
is up, your service is up,
and it can have one
pod or 10 pods or 100,
and we will vary those numbers.
We actively monitor the health.
We find that if in
production operations,
you have actually know which
pods are up and running
correctly.
One of the changes we've made
is to make it easier for you to
tell us when a pod
is working correctly.
We'll ask you, is this pod
working and if the pod can say
yes or no.
All right.
That ends up being a very
robust way to build systems.
Scaling, of course, is critical.
This is also inherent in
the load balancer, right?
So we do a lot of auto scaling.
I'll talk a bit more
about that in a minute.
And finally, I think,
the most important part,
because what's the essential
differentiator for Kubernetes,
it's really about evolution,
which is the orchestration.
All right.
Kubernetes makes it really easy
to have a running service and
upgrade that service while
it's running to a new version.
That is historically hard to do,
and a super important operation.
You can't take your service down
to upgrade it, that's not okay,
right?
And particularly when you
get to more complex projects,
you'll find you have many
different teams building parts
of a larger service, and you
really want every one of those
teams to have their own
independent updates.
That's how you get velocity.
So that's what you
want out of Kubernetes.
There's a few other things I
want to get across about just
the core of it that I think you
can always use a little more
explanation.
One of them is, this thing
that what is the cluster?
And it gets to how
we think about Borg.
So a pod is a collection
of containers,
that's the unit of deployment.
The cluster in Kubernetes is
essentially a collection of
nodes that you deploy pods onto.
And the Borg equivalent
of this essentially,
I think of it as being
the sea of resources.
When you're programming
internally at Google and you
want to run your job, Borg
gives you this literal sea of
thousands of places
that job can run.
And you don't think at all
about specific machines.
Your interface with the system
has nothing to do with machines,
it has only to do with these
places that can run containers,
right?
That is a wonderful place to be.
So the point here is if you
have this notion of a cluster,
this more like a
virtual cluster,
it is decoupled from the
applications that run on it.
So that means that one team can
manage the environment that you
run on, and another team can
actually run the application.
Right?
That makes all the
teams more effective.
That's an important decoupling,
the environment that you run on
from the actual application
you're trying to build.
Of course, in Google,
like in the Cloud,
we actually have one big
collection that lots of
different things
can run on, right?
So that's actually part of
the fun of the schedule.
The same decoupling
should apply for services.
So when I say services
are independent,
or what's the goal
of a microservice,
my primary goal is that it
is independently upgradeable,
that you can upgrade this
microservice even with other
parts of your
application not changing,
because that's what gives
different teams high velocity,
so that I can have a team
that's going quite quickly here,
unaffected by whatever's
going on in other teams.
That's hard to do and
microservice has done well to
give you that structure.
Oh, no, shoot.
Maybe we can go back one slide.
Thank you.
I'm happy to
announce GCPNext 1.2.
This has been a tremendous
amount of work by lots of
contributors over
the past few months.
It has a lot of
interesting features,
I think the most
obvious one is scale.
You can now run jobs
that can run on 1,000
nodes with up
to 30,000 pods.
That is huge, well -- it's
highly requested feature,
and really means that scaling is
not a practical limit for almost
every team.
I'd be surprised if you
need more than 30,000 pods.
If you do, great.
We're happy to host you.
You can be our new favorites.
Some of the things in 1.2, much
better control over ingress,
especially layer
seven load balancing,
jobs which is a way to
do batch scheduling,
so now you can do batch
scheduling -- batch jobs in
Kubernetes.
DaemonSets are allowing you
to have a daemon running,
one per node, which allows
you to do certain kind of
housekeeping things
like log rotation.
API to manage
running deployments,
to give you aggregated
statistics, for example.
And config map, which I'll
talk about in a little bit,
which is a new way
to do configuration.
So back to configuration.
So configuration is kind of
a mess today, I would say.
It's -- it's unsolved maybe.
Mess is too strong a word.
So we're good at
building things,
we have processes for that
that are pretty clean.
We're pretty good now with
containers and packaging those
things into runnable systems.
Then when you deploy it, it's
kind of a collection of scripts
and command line arguments and
things that are highly variable,
and it would be nice to
see if we can improve that.
So the two most
common approaches,
and we use both of
these internally,
are scripting and
configuration languages.
Scripting is just
what -- like you say,
you write scripts to actually
configure your nodes to put them
in the right state and
start the software.
This always works.
It's eminently powerful,
it can do anything,
but it's very fragile, right?
We find that, you know, if
something stops in the middle of
an initialization script, now
you're in this weird state,
you don't know how to fix it.
So how do you get
back to a good state?
It's very fragile.
So I don't like to use scripts
running at deployment time.
Another approach which is domain for the language configuration,
actually we've built many of these inside Google.
We don't have just
one, we have several.
And they are good in that
they're less verbose,
they're specific
for configuration,
so they're very efficient.
But they have problems, too.
For example, if I add a new
thing I want to configure,
I have to also add it to the
language before I can use the
language to fix it.
That's the lagging problem.
The other problem is
we have a new language,
you don't typically have all the
debugging support and tooling
support and eMax macros and all
the other things you might want
to actually make it usable.
So I think we could try a new
approach that goes back to the
idea of immutable
infrastructure.
Because that's really what
we're getting out of containers,
we're getting
immutable packaging.
Even pods are a kind
of immutability.
Pods give you a group of
containers that's immutable,
and they also give you
immutable port numbers,
which means if you
change IP addresses,
all the port numbers
stay the same.
It actually is quite handy.
Internally at Google, we
don't get that, by the way.
We run multiple jobs
on the same machine,
they share IP addresses, which
means you can't count on any
particular port address
being available.
So -- And yesterday we saw
Spinnaker doing lots of work
with this immutable
infrastructure focus for how you
configure things.
But really taking
it a step farther,
the core new idea that's in
this talk is the structure of a
multinode deployment ought
to be immutable, too.
The structure, right?
So in this model, you construct
a graph that is immutable,
that represents what
you want to run,
and then you deploy that
graph onto actual resources.
So I've broken deployment into
two steps, a construction step,
which is immutable, and a
deployment step which is
something you do actually once
you know you have what you want.
So when you think
about it this way,
it's really that we'd like
to have this new model of
construction, we want
a couple properties.
We'd like it to be a simple
declarative framework.
I don't want to use
a lot of scripting.
I don't want to have a
domain-specific language,
so the idea here is I'm
going to have a minimum DSL,
which is really YAML plus
some -- some parameters.
And if you need code, we're
going to use it to construct the
graph, not at deployment
time to run on the nodes.
Because construction is
an offline operation.
If it doesn't go
well, we can redo it.
All right?
We haven't actually deployed
anything when we're doing
construction.
So it is a low-risk operation.
The second thing we need out
of construction is it has to
support encapsulation and
composition so we can build
complicated things that
has some modularity.
Even if we did that, we would
still need some actual run time
configuration because the
graph is not sufficient for
deployment.
In particular, two
things don't fit.
One of them is keys.
I don't want to put my keys
in my container, although,
by the way, I see
people do that.
Don't do that.
Bad idea, right?
People can see your images and
they can see the keys inside the
image, right?
So the Kubernetes answer to that
is called the secret volume.
And it's basically a mounted
volume in which your secrets are
stored, and we connect that
volume to the right node at
deployment time.
So it's totally out of band
from the packaging path.
That's the right model.
Now, with config map in 1.2,
we're extending that idea to
generalize config.
So any configuration
you want for a pod,
instead of passing it in through
flags or environment variables
or some other path, we're
going to put it in a volume,
and you mount that volume.
And it has a lot of advantages.
In particular, the volume itself
can now be part of construction.
I can build a graph and say
these are the volumes to contain
the config and the secrets
that we want to use at our
deployments.
We can now update config
in a reasonable way.
Like if you want to update
config using environment
variables or using flags, you
have to restart the service,
right?
In this model, it's a
volume, it's attached.
You can just rescan
the volume, right,
so it makes updates simpler.
And finally, puts all the config
in one place that's easy to have
auditing and source code
control over, right?
So you can look in the
volume and see what's there,
it's very clear what the
configuration of a running
system is.
One problem we have inside
Google is that after a job is
running, we don't know how
it was configured, right?
We can't introspect to see
exactly how it got set up.
That's a mistake, right?
We're not repeating that
mistake with Kubernetes.
So now if I go back to
the flow of configuration,
I would say we do our
build, we do our packaging,
and now we do construction,
which is we define the topology
of what we want to deploy, in
this case it has a front end and
a back end with multiple nodes.
By the way, I don't have to fix
the number of pods in horizontal
scaling.
When I say fix the structure,
I'm saying this is a
variable-size front end, but I
don't have to know what the size
is.
That, I can change at run time.
Then once I know what I want to
deploy, then I can deploy it,
right, and that's
a separate step.
So really we have a mounted
volumes for our secrets,
we have a construction phase
and a deployment phase.
This leads to the final little
bit I want to talk about,
which is I just told you
conceptually about the idea of
construction, but I haven't
given you any tools to do it.
And so the last part is
the tools to do that.
And so our approach on this
is to make these graphs be
essentially a type system.
So we're going to have a type
for everything you want to
build.
So if you want a front
end, that's a type, right?
And the metabolic half
of this is constructors,
as in Java or C++.
So I have a constructor
with arguments.
It builds an object
of that type, right?
And it's a thing that runs
once at construction time,
and it gives you an
immutable output,
which is the
parameterized resource.
So these nested types have
meanings that are useful,
right, that really is, front end
is a thing with meaning.
You can have one team define the
front end and another team use
it, because it's a
well-defined type.
These graphs can get
quite complicated,
and so we do use code,
but not for scripting.
We'll use it at
construction time.
So for anything you
want to construct,
you can have
construction time code,
currently Python and Jinja, that
can actually generate the graphs
locally using whatever
logic they want.
So that's actually hosted.
You can use that to decide how
you want to build your system.
The instantiation of this so far
is Google Deployment Manager.
This is a new framework that
gives you essentially a way to
use parameterized templates,
with this kind of recursive
resource construction, which
I'll show you in a second.
In particular, it supports
the construction model and the
deployment model separately.
It does both, but they're
actually separate things.
And then what you get out of
this overall is you get the
ability to have not only
front-end managers for all the
Google primitives, but
you can make your own.
So essentially, this is
an extendible type system.
You make your own types, you
share them with your teams,
and then they can
build on them, right?
So here's an example.
It's going back to
the constructor idea,
it's really
parameterized template.
So the YAML file is the
arguments to the constructor.
This says, oh, this is a thing
with a front end and back end
that runs in us-central1, and this is the production version,
not the testing version.
That is the input to
a type, a template,
which when you execute,
produce this separately,
a front end and a back end.
And these are in black, because
I want you to think of these as
black boxes.
Some other team may have defined
what a front end is and a back
end is, and you're
using them in your type.
So we do get encapsulation.
Now, expanding those out, they
are just types themselves that
have parameters and templates.
And they recursively
get expanded.
They'll actually expand to,
oh, this is how you implement a
front end, it has these kind
of nodes with these disks,
has this load
balancing settings,
has these firewall rules.
That is inside the front end
and back end respectively.
So we're getting actually
that recursive graph structure
through this
construction process.
Now we have an immutable
well-defined description of our
deployment, and now we
just deploy it, right?
And which means that will be a
repeatable process and very easy
to make sure it gets
done exactly right.
Very robust.
I'll just go through
this relatively quickly.
This does fit well with this
model of secrets and config.
Because, again, the structure
includes the secrets volume and
the config volume, and so
when we do the deployment,
you kind of wake up and on your
pod is the data you need for
configuration and
for the keys, right?
They're just magically
in the right place.
Finally, it's not enough that
this be something that we can
use on GCP.
We are the open Cloud, we
believe in open source,
and this is an open
source project itself.
So we've been working with
DAES on their Helm project,
which we're fans of, and
we've added this construction
capability working
with them to Helm,
and you can go check
this out on GitHub.
I would say it's almost ready,
it's definitely in progress and
usable and interesting.
They have a notion of a chart,
which is very similar to our
type system, so we extended
that to include this kind of
construction.
There's an example, the helm
installed redis-cluster.
That basically means,
redis-cluster is a defined type
of a thing they made, and you
can install it as a thing.
That is a deploy step
given the instruction.
That's what's next for config.
I'm super happy to be here
today, and thank you so much.
[Applause]
>> Thanks, Eric.
I love -- while
Eric was talking,
I saw an analyst from Redmonk
tweeted fan boy moment,
Eric Brewer on stage.
That's my day every
day I come to work,
is I get to work with people
that are just amazing thinkers,
doers and builders.
That wraps up our Day
Two event this morning.
I want to thank you again for
your time, for your attention,
for your contributions to
everything that we do in Google
Cloud Platform together.
I hope you enjoy the rest
of your day here at the event.
Please interact with us online
and here and throughout the
coming weeks and months.
Thank you and enjoy
the rest of your day.